this very tight you know to give any
chances at all look at what rook look at
white's rook it's stopped any potential
checks farouza he's getting angry as
well getting frustrated white's rook
stops checks and it guards black's pawn
from advancing yeah
perfect
technique totally yeah incredible and uh
and also take a look at the white rook
you know it's beautiful it's a maximum
checking distance which is the term we
use just to say that the
rook will check from far away and now
you this is important give a check to
the king drive it away and then you can
pick up the pawn
yeah he picks up the pawn
and uh yeah this one i'm just seeing
it's popped up there grind like a grand
master this is a grind an end game grind
worthy
of anyone prague his end game skills
just wow let's just remind everyone that
means that's your your chessable course
which people can now buy david right
yeah and uh we'll talk about it
but yeah he's won the same game prague
360 turn around from a losing position
and he won incredible by pragnanda he
takes the lead